wurf abschlag vom gegner und sport und
vor allem immer wieder kopf einziehen
der ball kann schnell werden bis zu 160
kilometer pro stunde
kricke wird eigentlich auf gepflegtem
rasen gespielt aber kapitän ist ahmad
vom team des msv bautzen ist schon
glücklich über die kleine halle
[Applaus]
hier sind leute aus pakistan afghanistan
und indien
sie sind alle gekommen um diesen sport
zu spielen wenn sie kein krieg hätten
würde das bedeuten
sie hätten gar nichts stolz präsentieren
sie im flüchtlingsheim ihren ersten
pokal
viele spieler sind erst seit kurzem in
deutschland sie warten auf anerkennung
als asylbewerber aus dem flüchtlingsheim
kommen sie nur selten raus es kann auch
gefährlich werden
ihr neues zuhause ist bautzen in sachsen
mit seiner tausendjährigen altstadt
eigentlich hübsch hässlich dagegen wie
sich hier immer wieder der fremdenhass
entlädt im februar legten unbekannte
feuer in einem haus in dass asylbewerber
einziehen sollten
im september skandierten rechtsextreme
zwei nächte lang gegen ausländer und
flüchtlinge
auch ahmad und einige seiner freunde
wurden schon bedroht wir trafen auf eine
gruppe von 40 oder 45 männern in
schwarzer kleidung mit bierflaschen und
baseballschlägern sie sagten geht weg
hier und kommt nie wieder hierher das
nächste mal lassen wir euch nicht
entkommen
dann sind wir abgehauen nach dieser
nacht hat ahmad lange mit sich gekämpft
kann ihm diese stadt eine neue heimat
werden trotz der fremdenfeindlichkeit er
hat entschieden ja zumindest vorerst
wenn ich wegen solcher sachen immer und
immer wieder flüchten muss dann wird es
für mich sehr schwer in dieser welt zu
überleben
da ist er eben ganz sportsmann einer der
sich durchbeißt und cricket hilft ihnen
dabei heute treten die bautzener ging
eine mannschaft aus tschechien an
kein leichtes spiel das gilt auch für
die regeln beim cricket
man kann sagen eine mannschaft wirft die
andere schlägt den ball so weit wie
möglich weg aber das ist nur eine von
vielen optionen bei diesem spiel zu
punkten
[Applaus]
kricket ist in deutschland eine
randsportart
durch die flüchtlinge ändert sich das
gerade im vergangenen jahr lösten 40.000
neue zum größten teil gut ausgebildete
spieler aus sri lanka afghanistan oder
pakistan einen krieg boom aus die zahl
der teams hat sich fast verdoppelt
der ehemalige deutsche nationalspieler
volker beck sieht riesige chancen auch
für seinen club wir haben unseren verein
dadurch wieder besser aufgestellt wir
waren sozusagen am ende eines zyklus wir
hatten viele gute spieler verloren in
den letzten jahren und haben jetzt viele
junge neue hungrige und sehr talentierte
leute dazu gewonnen
das team aus tschechien hat zwar auch
viele spieler aus südasien aber keine
flüchtlinge die es regelmäßig verstärken
das macht den coach der tschechischen
mannschaft etwas neidisch
während angela merkel fast jeden
reinlässt ins land lässt unser präsident
alle draußen und das ist hart wir haben
keine flüchtlinge gekommen zwar durch
unser land aber nur um weiter nach
deutschland zu reisen
er scheint ahmad will sich in
deutschland integrieren und mit cricket
eine brücke bauen
dabei helfen ihm schüler und lehrer aus
der region
sie unterstützen die cricketspieler
suchen plätze und hallen helfen bei der
organisation der spiele so hoffen sie
spieler und einheimische
zusammenzubringen
aber das ist schwierig wir haben einfach
mal anschauen wollten was ist denn
überhaupt geld viele kannten sich und
sind einfach mal interessehalber stehen
geblieben und es gab aber auch schon die
situation dass leute da waren und sich
am training beteiligt haben und ich
denke das ist doch ein guter anfang
der msv bautzen siegt an diesem tag
gegen das tschechische team und jeder
sieg hilft den flüchtlingen sich in
bautzen wohler zu fühlen
trotz allem
sie haben etwas das ihr leben jetzt
wertvoller macht und außerdem können sie
all die dinge vergessen die sie auf
ihrer flucht erlebt haben einfach
spieler sein und nicht mehr nur
flüchtling das ist ihr rezept so wollen
kapitän ahmad und seinem team gegen den
hass auf alles fremde in bautzen an
spielen und wenn möglich gewinnen
[Applaus]